dans les dix neuf départements en
vigilance renforcée ces règles seront
étendues à tout le territoire
métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
nous faisons le choix de la
responsabilité et si je puis dire de la
respiration
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile
oui il faut freiner le virus aussi nous
allons fermer durant trois semaines les
crèches les écoles les collèges et les
lycées
mais oui nous devons préserver
l'éducation et l'apprentissage à partir
du 16 avril
les premiers rendez vous seront accordés
aux personnes qui ont entre 60 et 70 ans
à partir du 15 mai les premiers
rendez-vous seront ouverts pour nos
concitoyens qui ont entre 50 et 60 ans a
retrouvé cet art de vivre à la française
que sont les restaurants les cafés que
nous aimons tant je reviendrai vers vous
prochainement pour préciser un agenda de
réouverture et pour que chacun puisse
aussi se projeter avec plus de
visibilité dans les mois qui viennent
dès la mi mai nous recommencerons à
ouvrir avec des règles strictes certains
lieux de culture nous autoriserons sous
conditions l'ouverture de terrasses et
nous